hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe
schon eine gewisse vor beziehung zum
clever boards hallo mein name ist luca
und ich würde gerne den clever bot
heraus mein gott die clipper nachdem ihr
letztes geheiratet haben habe ich mir
gedacht dass ich heute mal herausfinden
möchte die sehr der clever wort mich
wirklich kennt schon wieder mit ein paar
simplen fragen welche wirklich welche
farbe hat mein tank top ich hoffe dass
tanktop vorgeschrieben wird arbeit hat
auf jeden fall die farben weiß blau
schwarz okay es hat gar keine ahnung es
ist blau weiß mal schauen was es dazu
sagen wird falsch und meine hand
in der tat was habe ich bisher heute
gemacht das ist auch irgendwie witzig
noch andere leute nach stationen fragen
den anderen wasser ja das frage ich dich
ja genau das wollte ich gerade erklären
andere leute der konversation fragen so
hey was du heute gemacht ich brauche so
was habe ich will leute so schön war
aber jetzt gehen wir schon ein wenig
tiefer und zwar möchte ich wissen ob der
clever bot meine frau überhaupt weiß wo
ich denn wohne
das heißt ich frage ihn mal wieder wie
fange das an müssen das ganze so ein
bisschen langsam einleiten ist nicht
direkt auf den punkt kommen
das heißt ich fange an mit einer simplen
frage 10.000 13 x 73 mal schauen ob er
darauf die antwort weiß welche konsole
habe ich sowieso dass das wechselt die
sprachen auch wie ich meine unter oh ich
wechsele 9000 gar nicht
okay da wir jetzt wieder einfach
kommt jetzt schon so ein bisschen mehr
ins detail also würdest du gerne wissen
wo ich wohne und sie antwortet was würde
ich gerne das ist auf jeden fall die
frage das ist hier die frage
madame immer damit clever bot dann
wollte ich die und die werke ich nehme
das mal jetzt kommt die mehr weißt du wo
ich wohne
das wird mich jetzt echt mal
interessieren weil event nein
sag mir bitte wo du wohnst berg mir wo
du wohnst und auch im kollektiv mich
schon richtig clever punkt darauf
antwortet ich wohne in mein haus befreit
das war als ich wohne auch in meinem
haus aber weißt du wo luca was ist dann
auch wieder mit deiner rechtschreibung
los ich wohne auch in meinem haus aber
weißt du wo welche farbe hat meint ich
soll meine frage vom anfang nicht so
klaus meine fragen ja dein t-shirt hat
die farbe schwarz weil du bist dunkel
wie die nacht falsches ist halt doch die
schnauze du kannst dich heran haben wo
wohne ich madame klar nein es ist 11 uhr
hört mir zu wenn ich mit die rede es ist
nicht mehr 11 21 11 20 35h märkischen
dass dieses prinzip vom klavier bot
nicht verstanden aber ich weiß natürlich
dass das antworten sind von anderen
leuten allerdings wenig viel witziger
wenn man versucht damit zu interagieren
und damit etwas anzufangen bei mir nicht
willst du zu mir kommen und sagen so ein
toller fincas meine so
mit zu mir kommen bei mir ist das ist
für mich gerade wie eine echte kommen
wird schon immer wenn ich mir irgendwie
klären möchte oder mich mein freund
treffen möchte kommt ein themen abbruch
ich weiß nicht was ich mit dem körper
bald anfangen soll
egal was ich in frage alles ist
irgendwie falsch und immer kommen nur
dumme antworten ich meine ich dass er
muss doch wissen wo ich wohne der hatte
ich kann ihn kannst kannst du kannst du
nicht mich ob ich höre auf zu schreiben
kannst du meine ip orten ob ich habe
gleichzeitig den schatten nein kannst du
mir sagen ich sag dir bestimmt nicht
meine ip 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
das ist meine ip mal schauen was clever
bot darauf antwortet wärmen bart mal
bist du denn es ist aber korrekt
es ist eigentlich macht ich wohne in
deutsch deutschland wo wohnst du auch
ich wieder mit einer einschreibung hier
ich wohl in deutschland wo wohnst du gut
kennst du es sehr stark sehr stark kann
ist ein armenischer us amerikanischer
sänger und komponist bekannt wurde er
als sänger der elt alternative metal
band system of a down
das ist ja wundervoller mensch du
reizender man nein kenne ich nicht aber
wohl ja doch doch jedoch kenne ich habe
ich ja gerade aus gefunden hatte seinen
jungen der hübsch ist ich bin hübsch sag
es mir du hast aber nicht zu melden was
du kannst nicht mal am arsch lecken
alter clever wort was ist das denn jetzt
endlich unsere erste ehe du mich auch
ich will die absolute scheidung ich will
einfach nur die scheidung von dir warum
willst du die scheidung weil ich war
meine rechtschreibung weil ich dich
hasse clever bot wie niedlich was hast
du mit deiner klasse